madame girard bonjour bonjour monsieur
roy merci de nous avoir écrit c'est à
peine si nous autres on vous remercie
d'être venus nous rencontrer
casey de recevoir dans des quartiers
puis on accueille une de vos voisins et
saint-amand bonjour bonjour merci d'être
là on est en plein de nouveaux quartiers
de montréal dont on a beaucoup parlé des
fois pour pas de bonnes raisons mais
vous aimez vivre ici vous avez votre pea
devant vous devant nous et marié ça
qu'il ya un magasin mais je pense que un
cas un quartier pour qu'il y ait une vie
de quartier ça prend des services et je
crois que les gens au fil des années je
pense à fait au dessus d'eux au delà de
dix ans je pense que les gens attendent
ce ces services-là ses magasins long
quand on crée un quartier il faut penser
à ça c'est ce que vous dites
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr un quartier
c'est pas seulement des maisons avec des
familles ici comme deux général des
générations qui se côtoient des
retraités avec des jeunes familles parce
qu'il s'est plaint de jeunes familles
avec des enfants puis ça ça fait une
belle dynamique dans le fond madame
girard ce que j'ai aimé justement dans
parce qu'on va présenter du sujet c'est
qu'il ya les deux générations
vous vous êtes une mère vous avez des
enfants vous habitez dans un condo donc
rpo la con dau la moderne puis vous
voulez la même chose en fait exactement
nous on veut on veut non seulement une
épicerie mais au-delà de ça on veut un
lieu où on peut se rassembler comme un
noyau villageois un peu puis on ne
vraiment pas ça on n'a rien à proximité
à distance d'un marche à part quelques
exceptions la rue sherbrooke qui est au
sud du quartier faubourg contrecoeur une
barrière pour les gens ici pour se
rendre vers les commerces au sud de
sherbrooke
comment ça c'est qu'on entend c'est 5000
personnes dans des nombreuses fermes et
des milliers de familles puis de leur
offrir absolument à rien comme service
on a saturé en plus les services qui
étaient présentes déjà dans le quartier
donc un manque de ressources pour la
population de mercy est bon c'est pas la
place qui manque on le voit le jour
s'ils avaient personnes qui voulaient
aller l'as une chose mais il y avait un
projet que la ville ont refusé que ça ça
vous choque
oui ça nous a beaucoup choqués je pense
que ça a touché les gens on est allé au
conseil d'arrondissement
très souvent on est allé à la descente
questionné madame plantes la même chose
on s'est déplacé beaucoup pour ne les
puits déjà mais l'os sabatier aux
politiques
ouais ça vous êtes déçu aussi énormément
et ça m'a énormément déçu parce que
c'est après ce projet là il prive 2008
on parle que le projet était refusant
2018 deux heures plus tard un projet qui
n'était pas parfait mais qui était
excellent pourrait ça réponde énormément
aux besoins de la population qui avait
été consultée à maintes reprise dont
entre autres par l'office de
consultation publique de montréal qui en
étaient venus à la conclusion que le
projet de four bears répondait aux
besoins des citoyens
on peut comprendre que leur vision était
de faire rentrer de l'amsa sans
précédente mais on aurait aimé
comprendre c'était quoi leur club match
mais on n'est jamais si c'était quoi
leur plan de match taxes qu'ils ont une
super bonne idée il va laisser partir
mais qui nous le vrai c'est quoi leur
plan masse qui piquent is grouille
exakis grue déjà très éloquente
merci beaucoup merci on va aller poser
des questions à la ville merci vous
pierre lessard blais bonjour aux
auxerrois
comment ça se fixe pas encore fait on a
vraiment hâte que ça arrive nous aussi
on partage entièrement les
préoccupations des citoyens qui veulent
une vie de quartier puis des commerces
de proximité donc on a très hâte que ça
arrive oui mais deux minutes là pourquoi
vous avez refusé notre comité
consultatif en urbanisme qui est pas une
instance politique mais qui plus
administratif
à noter plusieurs lacunes au projet
c'est quoi le problème
la sécurité on le sait une résidence de
personnes âgées juste à côté et toute
personne qui allait venir à pied il ya
la voir des enjeux importants de
sécurité pour se déplacer du côté est au
côté ouest de contrecoeur voyons voyons
les gens madame laure qui viennent nous
parler km de marche et les gens
regardent le marché traverse une rue la
sécurité mais écoutez il ya un grand
stationnement qui vient avec l'espace il
faut que les gens puissent traverser au
stop faut que le stop faut que les
russes ou en ligne au quatre titres
tantôt on parlait aussi écouter les airs
et les deux ex monsieur roy ceux des
experts en urbanisme qui ont dit qu'ils
avaient des enjeux de sécurité pour les
piétons qui traversent la rue avec les
aménagements guère été fait car vous à
vous ajustez puis à mettre des stocks
mais des voix par son épouse
c'est pour citoyens de pays le fait que
rien maintenant parce que la ville a pas
été assez rapide
on a voté plus un règlement qui ont qui
permettait des dérogations pour sobey's
qui développent leur épicerie la
première fois qu'ils sont faites un
dépôt le ceto mois de 2018
je comprends la frustration des citoyens
il ya des gens qui ont déménagé ici en
2010 2012
il se faisait dire par des promoteurs
savent ouvrir en 2015
ça pouvait pas ouvrir en 2015 le premier
projet formule qui était déposant
l'arrondissement c'est en ou 2018 les
citoyens exigent de la vie de quartier
la première proposition de sobeys
c'était pas une vie de quartier
c'était des commerces qui donnait dos à
la rue contrecarre et tout le quartier
si on avait si le comité consultatif en
urbanisme avait accepté le projet lorsqu
on marcherait sur la rue contre carlos
sastre et un derrière de sandales qu'on
aurait eu quel effort par ailleurs vous
faites auprès d'autres commerçants pour
attirer
la saq un bureau de poste un jim un
nettoyeur à ce qu' il ya des gens qui
essaient d'attirer ces gens là ici oui
ce qu'on prépare ici c'est pas seulement
un seul commerce il ya une série de
commerce qui va venir donc le mais le
propriétaire du terrain s'est sauvé
c'est lui qui va décider quelle bannière
vont venir nous notre travail c'est la
planification c'est l'intégration mais
après ça moi c'est pas moi qui va lui
dire tu rentres tu es sorti exactement
au 28 ans restaurants de tacoz ou en vue
des pires des pires hausse le sait ça va
être à lui de décider
alors vous dites quoi en conclusion aux
citoyens qui attendent ils vont attendre
combien de temps
premièrement la première chose que je
dis c'est qu'on veut que ça se passe on
veut une épicerie de quartier on veut
des commerces de quartier puis on a un
os x est arrivé si j'avais eu la
possibilité de développer un projet
rapidement l'on leur effet c'est certain
ce que je dis c'est on y travaille on a
eu un avis préliminaire favorable en
octobre dernier
on n'entre que sobeys dépose une autre
demande formelle suite à cet avis
préliminaire favorable de cet automne
qui ont vu que le dossier de l'a 20
c'est sûrement pied assurément pas
agréable pour nous de voir cet espace-là
qui vit depuis que réel besoin citoyens
puis en tant qu ancien commerçant je
crois commerce local
mais très bien être humain on va suivre
ça merci à ce roi
merci au revoir